Xbox boss Phil Spencer has come out to
explain why Square Enix's final fantasy
14 a realm reborn is not available on
xbox one echoing a similar sentiment to
what we've heard from him before Spencer
told IGN it's business you see us doing
less third-party exclusive deals now I
found it's not something I'm a huge fan
of earlier this month Spencer said I
want to have strong third-party
relations but paying for many
third-party exclusives isn't our
long-term strategy Microsoft currently
has a major third party exclusive deal
lined up for later this year when rise
of the Tomb Raider will land on Xbox one
first that said the Xbox bot insists
that this is not a typical exclusivity
arrangement as Microsoft is actively
involved in the game's development and
will serve as its publisher Spencer has
told Xbox one owners not to expect many
more third-party exclusives going
forward as they're more interested in
focusing on their own franchises in
future interestingly back in May
PlayStation exec Andrew House said
almost the exact opposite as far as
Sony's approach was concerned he
explained that content deals with
third-party games like Destiny's street
fighter 5 and call of duty black ops 3
our interval to Sony's business plan
Phil Spencer said that Microsoft will
instead leverage its to do relationship
for exclusive content and features for
multi-platform games let me know down in
that comment section if you're a fan of
exclusives or if you'd like to see
everything go multi-platform for all the
latest in gaming be sure to stay tuned
to GameSpot's